dear mr Turner I say this is a father
who dearly loves my son as much as you
must love yours
brock is not the victim here if his life
has been deeply altered is because he
has horribly altered another human being
this young woman will be dealing with
this for far longer than the
embarrassingly short six months your son
is being penalized this is why so many
men believe they can do whatever they
please to a woman's body without
accountability this is the reason so
many victims of sexual assault never
step forward this is why white privilege
is real and insidious and usually those
with it are oblivious to it the story
here is that young men have choices to
make and these choices define them it
feels like you want more sympathy and
goodwill toward your son than you want
for the survivor of his crime you should
listen to her story you love your son
and you should but love him enough to
teach him to own the terrible decisions
he's made for now though from one father
to another help us teach our children to
do better by letting them see us you
better